[Music]
yo here we
are good to be back Scot it's a scotch
day we're doing a by the way this is a
Nick Offerman Logan a toast to Nick
Offerman for winning the awards Golden
Globe there you go we got some golden
drinks here oh that smells good that is
[__] book that is Smoky mhm
that is smokier than Sarah Huckabee
Sanders eye hey hey nice or a Snoop
Dog's
astray that is good stuff well well uh
yeah man how you been good remember when
he qu he said he quit smoking for about
8 seconds and then it was all Snoop Dog
and it was all a ruse to sell his
smokers or his barbecue [__] what do
you mean he's like I quit smoking weed
and like you know the [__] internet
get attention yeah and then he's like
just kidding byebye my smoker or
whatever smokeless grill that was it
smokeless Grill there you go quit
smoking I got advertising but boy did it
work and I'm sure he sold a that's the
new game now it's just how the [__] do I
make a splash cuz everything's all over
the Internet you know so how do I stand
out for a second I'm gay see me in
Denver this weekend there you go that
would work that would work I'm on The
Client List see me in
Denver aren't you glad you're not on
that list that's nice I still
wake up we too young to be on that list
if we were on that list we would be on
it for the other
reason worst summer job I ever
had you're just on you're giving stepen
hawy a massage not to turn them on just
to awaken some parts right right what up
with that plane so many people are on
that [__] plane and I assume that not
all of them are [__] Myers no well
you would have gone on that plane if he
asked you yeah it's a rich guy with a
jet you you would have [__] the minor
if he asked you too see my show
Dallas yeah yeah I think it's a it's a
ride I think some sometimes like I think
about being on the road they're like oh
my friend's got a i KN I know a guy
who's a billionaire I just met him
through he's like he liked my comedy so
we became like Pals through that and I
remember one time I was on the runway in
LAX he's like are you going to he text
me are you going to LA today I would
have taken you on my jet oh and I was
like I don't know I don't think he's
done anything bad sure but I was like
[__] I would have I would have done it
hell yeah i' do anything he asked me to
do I'd suck his
dick yeah I mean how was the house how
was his how awesome great house but I
mean like you know of course it's a
great house that's true great he just
lived in like a a
studio being specific how did he make
his fortune I I don't want to talk about
it it's too specific yeah okay I think
everything's Tech now I assume it's Tech
[__] but I don't know how that works
anyway so yeah but Mark met him I did
yeah we went out with him one day oh
yeah very unassuming yeah you would
never think yeah he's like 11 years old
this guy you know we had a fun night
that was a fun night a rare night of
marking Sam at a New York City nightclub
nightclub that ain't our scene we we
didn't you know but that's a different
world I remember you were single at the
time and we we saw this girl walk by we
were both like God damn and you went up
and you went hey and she
went you have to be more
specific damn yeah there were some hot
chicks I mean the [__] warriors were
there Draymond Green and Klay Thompson
walked in wow yeah I was like all right
this is the place to be I guess I know
just you've probably walked by that door
8,000 times it's like in the East
Village you go in it's a [__] crazy
yeah wild nightclub this is good scotch
so good Offerman does it again could you
get caught up in that lifestyle could
like if you're like could I yeah no no
no it's just not us it's funny
intoxicating it's too loud intoxicating
yeah it's for people with no personality
the music's so loud you can't have a
conversation it's for people on on drugs
you do drugs you make eye contact you
make out you got like get out of here
and this is a no the are all NOS for you
well it's high scho why don't want to
kiss them
again it's high school like sequel It's
just like who's hot who's not who's cool
who's where and what who's in the no
who's in the mix it it sucks but Mark
and I also like I feel like we Thrive
based off our personalities and not
based off how we look like when I got
laid it was like me it was me like
making a woman laugh at a bar so it
wasn't it wasn't me just like walking up
to it like you yeah that's like that's
some like Emperor [__] no no that's what
you get at the courtroom him you yeah 10
months later that's the man right there
yeah so no that that is not my world and
I it's cool to go see and like observe
like a safari you know like look at her
look at him there's that celebrity but I
feel you feel I feel out of place the
whole time I'm like I'm not cool enough
I'm not hot enough I'm not tall enough
I'm I'm too weird yeah the whole thing
very attractive hey you too if I was one
of those models I'd [__] I'd suck you
off dude well when I was single I would
literally go up to girls at a bar and be
like
Conan what what why else would she want
to talk to me both of us I think both of
us had a Conan uh Tinder pick oh yeah oh
yeah good ice breaker yeah what else am
I doing more matches if a girl's going
to be like huh look at
these that's my tits yeah you know is
being Fallon
I got nothing I'm 510 I you know I
didn't have any money what what else did
I have to offer cou it's it's exciting I
think for a woman it's like you know
I'll try I'll I'll give it a try it's a
different thing let's see if he's
actually fun like he's professionally
funny let's see if we go out and he
actually makes me laugh totally but uh
did you guys ever oopsie did you guys
ever um match with anyone sort of fancy
on Rya yeah I didn't do the Rya yeah
yeah I got I got a few but but I'm not
[__] saying that's weird well just
give me like a ballpark
ballpark actress or she was in B movies
she had b cups um I all right fine I
once [__] uh Kathy Bates Dame Judy
Dench all right there we
go yeah no I'll tell you off Fair okay
all
right this is getting good Gypsy
Rose I'm the one who killed her
mom and I I never got caught neither by
the way they show the mom's body dead
it's it's it's [__] just the whole
thing's horrific everybody's ugly and
trashy and it's the kids the boyfriend's
like an autistic weirdo Gypsy Rose
before Gypsy H dude
yeah woo put that in the bank dude uh
yeah we we had we had I mean Mark and I
would get [__] lit up yeah I mean
those seller nights too those were the
best but you can't keep up with comedy
seller Serv they they go hard they go
hard they go hard in the paint I got to
say not to be this guy but I feel like
that world that lifestyle ended with us
I don't see young Comics pounding the
pavement uh drinking the night away and
then falling on the sidewalk a bad look
I think I think I think like we did it
when there were less cameras around true
true I mean Comics got a goddamn camera
with them I know but I think the the
problem is like I I did hear about a
comic at a New York club who got like
wasted and groped a bun other comics and
he's not getting spots anymore obviously
because he can't [__] grab a
coworker's tits yeah uh I heard about
that too and that kid is lucky that he's
not bigger I know ironically if he was
bigger he'd be [__] but the fact that
he's such a he's not really established
it's saving his whole career I know yeah
that was a you go to you got to behave
you got you got to be like Mark and I
would like get shitfaced but we weren't
like bad we're good drunks that's the
thing is that mean that's why you can
still drink at our age because no one
told us you got a problem and you got to
quit yeah I mean maybe a few girlfriends
but I don't listen to them and uh no but
seriously we don't I don't think we have
a like it was ever like a problem I
think we're pretty like lovey drunks
yeah and I think we got that out in high
school not the groping but like I was
like puking black you know you wake up
on a sidewalk you wake up on a couch and
you're like where the [__] am I then you
have to walk home for 2 hours that's a
bad look when you're when you're getting
older yeah exactly I did that [__] when
I was 16 I peed on a bunch of girls
couches cuz I would wet the bed like
that those were tough tough mornings I
paid for a lot of Dry Cleaning in
College because of the you know the
blood but no no but yeah just uh a lot
of like sorry I peed on your comforter
here's you know
$28 you know yeah that'll cover
it know it was the early 2000s no
inflation yeah you know uh those nights
so they take a toll man oh yeah they
take a toll on your body and and at a
certain point you're like [__] my life
and the shame don't forget the shame the
waking up like oh what did I do what did
I say I was thinking about that actually
because we talked about this last night
mad and I we were we were just hanging
out and we talked about you know when
you're a guy like Chappelle and you have
the money to get the IV every hangover I
know you don't have to deal with the
consequences drinking right so you kind
of you you feel like [__] for a minute
then you get the IV and you're like
let's [__] go again I'm back I need a
little shame to cut back on my drinking
if I shame the damage to your body stays
the same he is damaging his liver just
as much as you are but he doesn't feel
it like and it's not just Dave it's like
a lot of people yeah yeah maybe we
should not focus on that but yeah well
Burke too I mean Burke quit drinking
basically he'll have like a a beer here
there yeah he looks amazing that's why
he just cut down on the booze and then
we got drunk on the cruise I think I
talked about this and he was like this
sucks I'm hung over I I don't remember
anything like this is a bummer like how
did I do that for the last 20 years
hilarious that that Bert drank so hard
for the last 20 years he forgot what not
being hung over was like pretty much for
two decades and he pushed through for
the crew like all right I'll keep
drinking for the cruise but he was like
when I get off the cruise I'm going back
to no drinking well I I mean I text him
the other day I was like dude you look
amazing I mean like I saw the shirtless
picture of him and I was like that yeah
you look like a different person you
look healthier and also you don't he's
also like a strong guy and an athlete
you don't want to cut years off your
life you're a father and a husband and I
bet like Leanne also feeling his chest
being like could you stop drinking 47
beers a day sure this feels awesome
you're ripped yeah my parents came
famously they came to the show and my
dad was like he's got a
problem a button down tucked in with
slacks on he's like this is insane cuz
Bert chug would chug like a 16 oer and
then do the set and like throw it down
and the crowd would go nuts and my dad's
like that's insane he's gonna and then
we're drinking after he's like this is
too much I'm like he's the machine yeah
but when you're like an older person it
it's more it's more clear to you but I
remember like being like in high school
at dinner with my family and I like got
a second beer my grandfather's like he
had two beers yeah and I was like yeah I
get way more [__] up than this Pops I
know I'm taking it easy yeah but like
you know to them they're like what the
hell are you doing but also when you're
young you're like I'm going to bounce
back I'll be fine you know that's when
you hit your like mid to late 40s that's
when you got to like be a little careful
I know I know did I ever tell you about
the time I got I blacked out in high
school my friends dropped me off at my
house on the porch then shot the the
whole house up with paintballs my dad
comes out in a robe he's like go you
[__] kids and then he pulled me in
and I was with my high school girlfriend
at a time he spanks me in the hallway I
start laughing he's got me over his knee
he didn't know what to do cuz my dad's
not really good with feelings and stuff
so he's like God damn it you're a drunk
and I was like ah and then he starts
eating your
ass well that pissed him off more so he
just throws me upstairs and he goes you
stay down here and he put my girlfriend
in the living room and he interrogated
her he's like what's his problem why is
he drinking so much and she was
shitfaced in a Borno his dad would just
start [__] his
girlfriend dad stop very elaborate porno
with the paintball and everything it's
like Gran Torino he just returns fire
yeah kills all your friends he doesn't
know they paintballs that's true yeah my
dad was in the military too so he's not
[__] around but uh he's covered in
purple paint they're all in [__]
red all dead he just got did you see the
bandana tie you know he he's got the
artillery and a a armoir and he's like
I've been waiting for this and he goes
out there you [__] kids so I had to
clean the paintball [__] the next day
hung over but uh they sent me to
counseling what yeah so I had to go to
counseling and I was in there and I
remember being so mad at my dad cuz he
spanked me and he yelled at me and all
that and I've been counseling and the
lady's like so uh why do you why do you
drink so much is you do you have you
ever been beaten and I remember thinking
I could [__] my dad right now but I
didn't do it I was like no no I just I
like drinking it was fun so yeah I'm say
we got it all out in high school I had
uh I remember my parents we went to
Miami one year for like it was like my
dad had go there for work and he like
turned into a family trip and I went out
at night and I got [__] wasted and I
somehow ended up with uh with the
fireman's badge I don't know how I had
it I just found it somewhere so I was
just like I was just like using it you
know as a kid I was stupid so I remember
I smoked so much weed in high school and
this is when weed was like considered
very bad yeah and they found
it and they gave me as I'm high they
gave me an intervention what and my mom
as the kicker takes out the
badge oh wow I was like she's like
you're living a double life I'm like no
I just got drunk and I took a b so I had
to mail the badge back to the firemen
you think I was like what do you think
I'm like rolling in I'm like this is
under my jurisdiction now but my mom was
so [__] mad at me and you show up to
911 I'm here guys I got this yeah it's
not like a cop badge it's not like a
cool I just show up to a fire right
right but uh I was just a dumb kid yes
but my mom was like they were so mad
look I was always high I was just always
oh really you were that kid I was that
kid you're just like H life I know that
my my friend was like that but those H
Jinks were wild looking back cuz we're
lucky we're alive I mean the drunk
driving we did and the the fist fighting
and all this [__] like one time we were
at a bar we had no money we're at this
shitty die bar New Orleans this guy pays
for a high life I remember with a 50 and
he like turns around for a second and
the bartender puts like
$47.50 on the bar and I just went and I
took it and I go let's go get out of
here we got out of there and we just
[__] partied the night away we bought
like two handles of vodka you know we
just went to town with to [__] Burger
King and went to a parking lot we're
chug and [__] I mean it was horrible
you're like you're like John qak and
grifters yes yes exactly one time that's
going to go wrong though you know oh oh
yeah it went it went wrong a few times
the handle of vodka like pop off vodka
that was like the move or like uh
anything cheap that would get you [__]
up cuz when you're a kid that H you're
like you can kind of H you can deal with
a cheap alcohol hangover but then you
get older you're like I don't want to
[__] feel no I don't want to feel a
shitty cheap booze hangover but back
then it you didn't even think of Health
it was just like how can we get the most
[__] up for the cheapest smoking
blunts on the on the Stoops and stuff
and yeah and you're just like I'm a
[__] idiot I'm like but now it's like
it's so much better cuz as a kid it's
like peer pressure and you're like oh I
just got to do this but now I'm like I
enjoy it you know it's like yeah same
you yeah this is like great this is like
like I feel loose and good and uh I mean
it's our second one a day so we're a
little looser than normal but
uh Last Story one time we got [__] up
we were doing the uh the what the
aerosol in a grocery store and uh my
friend who is pretty smart he's like now
he lives in Seattle he's doing he's like
a lawyer he's married with kids he goes
I got a crazy idea we went out to the
parking lot there was a yappy dog in a
car with a window cracked and he goes
how about this we'll go back in we'll
give high again we'll steal a bunch of
laxative and dog treats we'll put the
laxative in the dog treat this kid was
pretty creative and he goes we'll slip
it through that crack in the window when
the guy comes back out his dog will have
[__] all over the car and I was like
you're a [__] genius so we we we got
all the [__] we stole the whatever and
then we went outside and gave it to the
dog and the guy goes hey get the [__]
away from my dog so we had to run away
so we never got to enjoy the the payoff
but you friends watched too many
cartoons that's amazing I mean just to
have the idea to do that I mean did he
maybe did he get that from like
something about Mary or something I
don't know I don't know where that's
what remember when they put the drugs in
the food and they throw it in that's
true that's true this was laxative but
yeah yeah those were wild times no phone
no camera I mean do you have like the
meet in the park we're all fighting that
whole [__] did you guys ever do that
stuff that was terrifying yeah but yeah
I remember I had one friend who was like
he was like the you ever have that one
friend who's like Untouchable yes he's
like the guy who's like [__]
everyone's girlfriend he's like the
piece of [__] but you're like hey
Survivor you got to love him until one
day I remember kid beat the [__] out of
him like bad and then he prepared to
beat the [__] out of him he brought a
bottle of piss with him so after he beat
the [__] out of him he dumped the piss
on him
whoa and I'm like I mean it's kind of
badass I guess but you could just piss
on him yeah it might give like nerves
there's nothing less cool than being the
[__] of someone whipping down be like
[__] I can't I can't go I had stage
fright I couldn't do it dick just out
but that kid it's funny how people grow
up CU that kid came to my show in uh
Bethlehem Pennsylvania and he was like
kind of like the hot badass kid and now
he's like kind of like shy and it's like
people grow up I mean everyone's like
you you become a different he's still a
sweet kid but like and he was actually
always nice to me but he got uh he got
he was like a cry for help kid he got
arrested in front of my home because uh
yeah in Chelsea no this upper side okay
so he he takes out a butterfly knife and
attacks cab and he starts carving
swastikas into it what the [__] is he
Jewish yeah it was it was a cry for help
that was just what you carve then and
then my mom my mom goes out and has to
see him get pulled away by the cops oh
no and it's like it's a hard time
convincing your mom that kid's going to
sleep over ever again my mom's like the
one who did the swas go I'm like he's a
Jew it was a cry for help he was a bad
kid to cry for help but uh but I saw him
in a show and he's like a shy kind of
like you know Tim it's a people
everyone's got their problems and he had
like a family that was [__] up
everyone's got their [__] you know like
like bringing a bottle piss to a fight
and then losing you got to walk home all
bloody with a bottle of piss in your
hand yeah that's brutal you dump it on
your own head I deserve this and I
[__] lost would have been the fight
you get kicked and it pops you know that
that's not good either yeah it's a tough
one right you got to really the PE is
it's so disrespectful like you think
getting spit on is disrespectful that's
uh I know but kid's fighting too you're
just like it's so stupid oh dude we had
a guy in our school he was like the bad
kid everybody knew his dad beat him like
in gym class we'd get shirts off and he
had just back his back was just bruised
and [__] up from who knows what and he
stole my friend's ball we were all
playing basketball and my friend he's
standing against a brick wall and he
goes give my [__] ball back and he
took it and you couldn't cross this kid
so he grabbed the ball from my friend
again and threw it at my friend's face
hit the face head hit hit the back of
the wall or back of the head hit the
wall passed out and seeing that you're
just like this is a this is a tough
school that's like a badass bully too
yeah why bad people always have great
aim have you noticed that like that one
kid would always like this is the kid
I'm talking about I remember one time he
just took a tennis ball and just gunned
it at me and it hit me right in the face
I was like how the [__] I know what are
you going to the major leagues that was
incredible I was angry but I was also
like oh my God they have no nerves so
they're not like they're never flinch
I just baby I don't think I got no
anxiety but this kid like wasn't an
athlete but he just had that gear to him
well I was like that was fast the way
you like you could gun it he wasn't like
I don't think he played sports or
anything but like I think he was
actually like he might have played like
hockey but it was like he was the Goon
yeah yeah you got to love that kid but
you're like he's got no athletic ability
but like he just walk up to a kid and
punch him in the face and you're like
all right Penalty Box you served your
purpose you scared the other team I love
the idea of you bringing a kid over and
your mom's like no you're like he's a
you he's one of us no my I remember like
uh no but you need that friend though
you like everyone has that friend who's
like kind of the bad influence but you
see the good in him and and like look
sometimes sometimes they push it too far
but sometimes you [__] you you know
like there's something about them you
admire where you're like that kid pushes
it to the Limit especially when you're a
kid and he would have your back in a
second if something went down like they
they have nothing to lose those kids he
did I remember one time we were walking
on the street and we were just like
drinking 40s on the street and this guy
like kind this crazy guy popped [__] and
we all [__] ran and he stood tall and
talk and talk [__] to him and the guy
respected him and we were like wow we're
[__] [__] we were like seventh grade
but but the fact that he like and also
was like what the hell are you doing in
seventh grade talking [__] to a grown
man but he did it and we were like man
this guy's kind of a badass you know
yeah we had a guy like that too Hunter
we uh we we're getting our car towed and
we were like [__] it we'll beat you guys
up you know it was just one guy and then
he's like oh yeah and then two giant
black dudes came out of the truck and
we're like ah cuz it was just two of us
and now three of them and my friend
stood there he's like I don't give a
[__] and we're like come on Hunter let's
get out of here and he stood there and
he goes you guys are [__] and this guy's
a real man but we're still Towing your
car and he towed the car yeah this is
what a real man is then they beat him to
death like just so you know that guy was
cool that we just killed and now he's
the president's son now he was the uh
treasure at a college and we're like how
the [__] did you get that he's like
we're going out tonight I got all the
alumni money he was still a piece of
[__]
but I don't know what he's doing now but
he was like a tough kid it's funny that
kid grows up and like uh like dude how
do you get fired from your job he's like
swastikas again I [__] I can't stop
uh but it's like we should bleep that
name actually but he was a he had a good
heart man people are people are [__]
up they're dealing with their [__] he
had he had bad stuff at home you never
know you never know what people are are
going through so I think like my mom
didn't see that but I saw that so I like
I felt for him you know he also
introduced me to one of my favorite
weird ass movies shout out uh Monkey
Shines old school I think it's a Stephen
King never heard of it it's Steven roots
in it uh that dude who
Scientology ground floor Scientology is
in it it's literally the funniest movie
ever it's like it's a horror but Stanley
Tucci's in it oh it's about a guy who's
like an athlete that guy you know from
the Scientology dog oh yeah and he and
he gets
paralyzed he gets hit by a car and he's
paralyzed from the neck down and they
get him a monkey helper the monkey is
like his personal assistant the monkey
can do anything and it's like oh my God
this monkey's awesome and then it turns
out people like his girlfriend leaves
him and starts [__] another dude and
the monkey gets mad and the monkey
starts like acting out his rage and
murdering people so he has to turn
against the monkey but he's still
paralyzed it's it's insane s great
amazing when I did Donnell's movie
podcast that's he was like you got to
pick a movie that doesn't have great
reviews and defend it yeah so that was
it was defend your movie it's a great
premise for a pod but I remember uh he
watched it he was like this actually a
pretty good movie I'm like it's pretty
[__] good and it started the monkey
cam it was like from Letterman well it
was like from the monkey he'd be in
money but like it'd be from his
perspective oh I'll watch that that's
it's kind of it's a it's a great like
ridiculous fun movie mhm uh I mean
you're going to laugh out loud a lot
sure sure what is this what's happening
here he's killing somebody with a
syringe I I can't see the picture it's
the monkey administering uh medicine or
something oh okay damn there's some dark
[__] in that movie it's it's pretty
crazy I'd say so he's holding a [__]
a razor with blood on it in the
poster well the monkey will shave him
the monkey will like he Lear he's it's
it's it's a ridiculous premise but like
I love movies like that that are just
like insane and stick to it and uh you
ever heard that Pat Oswald that old bit
about he's it's called deathbed and he's
like people had to come up like get a
call sheet come we're going to do
deathbed at 6:00 a.m. we got a lighting
guy like they had so much production
behind this movie and that's how I think
about with all these movies like there
was a grip there was a PA like I need my
coffee now we're doing Monkey Shine
what's the Rotten Tomatoes on that
salacuse cuz I wonder I wonder what we
got there yeah it's hilarious you just I
mean but the thing is like you don't
know if you're making something awesome
yeah you never exactly oh 53 53 um not a
great Audience by the fans I stand by it
I think it's kind of
fun I love movies like that because you
don't they don't really make these
anymore it's just such a wacky idea
exactly ha Mary and and it's like now if
you make it it's got to be like a little
more like you're making fun of it yeah
like I didn't see that movie cocaine
bear but it seems more like this by the
way that's what it takes to sell a movie
now you have to dumb it down that much
for an exec you need the you need the
synopsis to be the title yes it's a bear
that's on cocaine cocaine bear they're
like fck it exactly I know that's how it
is that well you've seen that Viral clip
of Seinfeld going around have you seen
that where he's like uh so I've noticed
in comedians he's getting interviewed
Comedians and Cars you have a lot of a
white men he goes we're doing this now
here we go and he goes completely ape
[__] I wish you if Jerry was just like
[__] you [__] dumb piece of [__] he
does his version he's like great yeah
let's talk about this this is what I
want to talk about and way by the way
the guy interviewing him a white guy
yeah yeah I mean it's like okay well
like you know what about your job should
we your job away let's bring in uh Cat
Williams I just think it's lame when
people are counting I think like
diversity is good of course diversity is
good but like when you're just When
you're counting and you're just like
yeah play it
mostly 22 Episodes let's get into
that but you the crowd's with them the
crowd loves it what do you cuz you know
what he's try you know what I don't like
about this guy it's a gotcha moment he's
trying he's like I'm going to get one
over on Jerry like he's almost like
proud of himself I remember guy brandom
did this at the seller like years ago
when like he did a whole he wrote this
whole piece like [__] the comedy seller
and their white males club by the way
look at the lineups it's pretty [__]
diverse there but uh it's booked by
women but yeah booked by an Israeli
woman but uh diverse lineups they
showcase all kinds of styles people of
all backgrounds and I remember on the
seller podcast he was like how many
trans people do you have here and Rich
Voss goes you have your own TV show how
many trans Writers Do you have oh and he
goes none and he's like okay then what
are we doing here why by the way there
are trans Comics at the seller yeah but
like what are you doing like these these
moments like they we're going to book
the comics that are right for this room
and the best comics and it's like you
know I of course like inclusion is great
inclusion is important diversity is
important but also like the idea of like
these H monitors I know know just
thinking like they're doing the Lord's
work by trying to bust a guy it's like
exactly what do you what do you think
and they don't realize that guy doesn't
realize he's being a bully he's bully
he's like I'm going to get you in
trouble right now this is going to look
really bad for you and it's going to be
very public and you're going to get
yelled at by the internet and all that
and you're like that that's mean you're
being mean I know you think you're
saving the world but you're doing you're
doing a mean thing under the guise of
moral superiority that's what I don't
like that's exactly what it is play play
the rest of it a lot of
Whitey he's talking about the crowd on
here but but oh this really pisses me
off oh he won't give him a minute I love
it really pisses me off people think
it's it's the census or something I mean
this is got to represent the the actual
pie chart of of of America who cares
it's just funny you know funny is the is
the is the world that I live in you're
funny I'm interested you're not funny
I'm not interested by the way his opener
is Mario Joiner on the road and like him
what wait what the [__] why is he with a
white
guy what the hell is that yeah I know
right but yeah it's just like him and
pro it up Julie Louie dfus now she's
great and we all love her I I don't know
it's
like why do we have to count and now
we're focusing more on race and now
we're now we're div dive div dicing it
up based on they want you to like not
see color but at the same time all about
check the boxes there's something so
insincere about that right uh well Elon
Musk you see that whole thing with Mark
Cuban what oh they went at it about Dei
on Twitter and uh I like Cuban but he
was going hard and musk I think might be
on drugs but uh wait you think well he's
like he's
really you know amped up these days is
hilarious how powerful he is and how
much influence he has and then like I
mean there was that whole thing I mean
when he went on Rogan and smoked weed
like you [__] up stock stock went way
down yeah I mean your shareholders are
like can you not get drunk on or high on
camera I know I know you're a
businessman yeah but either way they go
at it about Dei and he's like you know
musk is like this is actually inherently
racist you know we're judging people
based on the color of their skin and
Mark Cuban's like well it's actually
good to have diverse opinions and he's
like yeah I agree but it should be the
best and if the best happen to be this
and Mark Kuma won't let up and then musk
goes all right cool well let me know
when there's a a short Chinese woman on
the Mavs and you're kind of like it's a
good point you know I think mark C say
check and made I just hired one we
signed a Chinese old woman point guard
we move Kyrie Irving to the bench we'll
see how it plays out and and I hope they
do that cuz they're playing the Knicks
soon and uh but that would be funny that
would be hilarious cuz they would just
bench her they put her in for one second
you're running a company I mean this is
and I agree I like Mark Cuban a lot it's
easy for him to say once he sold exactly
the Mavs and this MAV stock uh got like
three something Mill and Cuban is
incredibly generous he just gave like 35
million to employees who work there I
mean like as a like I'm I'm out of here
I mean he's still there but he's he's a
minority owner now I think and that that
medicine [__] he does I forget I'm
[__] up the name give that a goo he
makes medicine cheaper for
great service he seems like a cool guy
and I honestly if you're listening to
this Cuban we'd love to have you on yeah
hell yeah uh and he does podcast oh yeah
he just did my old co-host Julian
edelman's P we love to have him on um I
like now he's a minority owner minority
owner so he because I think he is a
great owner like he turned that
franchise around but uh anyone who's
running a business you want the and you
want the business to succeed you want
the best yeah like the Mavs I'm sure
it's 98% % black which is great actually
the best player is Slovenian Luca Luca
Luka magic but Kyrie's their second best
player I kind of want to play a Luca
compilation can we do that real quick
why you love Luka I [__] love him
yeah he's great his his sports or his
his Sports comp okay I know he was fun
he's kind of funny okay he's great I
don't I thing about Luca though is I
don't know if I'd want to play with him
cuz he's like that he does that he holds
the ball so long that if I was a
teammate I think it would take me out of
it like yic I feel like is makes quicker
decisions but like I do I mean Luke is
phenomenal he's great like a ball hog
well look he just look at this ISO sh he
doing oh I see oh that was a nice pass
behind the back that was sick no he's
sick I mean he's like he gets some Larry
Bird comps for sure when are we going to
get a white guy from here but look up
Kyrie look up best of Kyrie and tell me
this this guy is not like a magician a
guy from white guy from here well we had
like Stockton and Larry Bird but I feel
like who who's the
who I don't know why I can't think of
him right now oh there's a kid actually
right now flag yeah but he's from uh
that's what I'm saying like they're all
from some other crazy Place yeah we got
um this guy I think it's Cooper flag
he's from Maine he's going to be
ridiculous oh the main event yeah yeah
that guy's awesome man me left-handed
this guy I mean this guy's one of the I
think Kyrie is the prettiest player I've
ever seen look at this [__] IR by Irv on
the
at the you're not even getting like his
best crosses and [__] that's where he
like wow good name Kyrie Irving I mean
he with the ball he's like a magician
Irv oh double fake with a turn where's
he from I think he's from Jersey origin
Jersey I him in high school
really wow he got everybody oh look at
that Dam you really see it on the replay
where you're like how the [__] did he
and that's on like a world class
Defender Drew holiday but uh do you
think Michael Jordan's sitting at home
going wow is he watching basketball you
think or is he sick of it I I don't know
if he does but he definitely like I
still think he thinks he's I shot him I
bet I bet he's so competitive he's still
watching like I'm better I bet if he
does like Jordan and he he's probably
right yeah I mean like I don't know cuz
Jordan's probably watching this guy like
yeah that was a hell of a move but he
would have done that move on me Jordan
was all defense every year too like
people forget like you're dealing with
the best on both ends and and there was
pride in that and I think like he if you
watch interviews with Jordan he'll be
like no player would ever beat me
one-on-one and they said what if anyone
could he goes maybe he goes maybe Kobe
cuz he steals all my moves
whoa you know but but he's like he was
like watch LeBron I'd beat him watch
Carmelo I'd beat him watch Kevin Durant
I'd beat him but like I think like but
then you see Kobe and he's like Durant
is the only guy I would have trouble
with cuz he's so [__] tall and
but you know look the game evolves it's
it's you know I'm worried about it I
think uh Jordan's hitting the cigars too
much cuz he's getting the the red eyes
you seen this let him live man he's he's
the best ever I just I mean I can't have
all the cigars he wants I'm just worried
about the guy I don't want him to get
the high blood
pressure it is funny that he could put
there's there's a clip of Jordan I don't
know if you ever seen this at Chris
Paul's uh at at Chris Paul's basketball
camp and they go you get a free pair of
Jordans if he misses one shot and he
doesn't miss the whole camp and he
doesn't miss one shot but then I think
he just gave one to everyone anyway but
like I mean yeah is this it oh this is
so [__]
funny what's this you get a free pair of
Jordan the whole Camp if he misses a
shot oh the whole Camp gets them yeah
wow that's a lot of shoes look at this
if he misses holy [__] this is a lot of
pressure yeah but this is what he lives
for he loves pressure that's true now
they hate that he's making it
that's hilarious they're booing him
ah oh that's
great and they're put
for oh my God I think he still just
gives them to everyone but it's like
that is hilarious that he's like I'm GNA
make every shot [__] them
kids well that's a win-win he got to
make all of them and they get the shoes
everybody's happy and he stole the goat
and you get to see you're like holy [__]
that's pretty cool yeah you get to see
Michael Jordan boy wouldn't you love a
photo with him verer has one we got
we're having verer on soon that's true
what's this story the story is amazing
yeah I love
thisr is the audio good enough
in this is Aman Shumpert you had a great
game you can't hear this the music the
music's killing this [__] I know why do
they do that with the music cuz they
think it's more dramatic but Shumpert
was the shooting guard in the Knicks
he's a great Storyteller Kobe the garden
I can't remember how much he had but I
know I had multiple steals against him
to where in the game in my head all I'm
thinking of is when I have this
conversation with my brother after the
game how I'm going tell him how I stole
a ball from Co that is pretty insane I'm
thinking about all these things in my
head I'm like so the fourth quarter
start wait you were already celebrating
fourth quarter
start got a love radio guys you had a
great
[Music]
game oh my God man come down you
remember he came shot fake shot fake
threw it off the glass called it threw
it to the corner I'm like bro
what get to the spot shop fake spin
pivot over here spit back on that's just
unfair then he pulled up like 35t on
some Steph Curry before Steph was doing
that he pulled up and laced it I'm like
they called the timeout Dan Tony looking
at me I'm like bro
I for the record that guy Shumpert was
like a really good defensive player what
happened he won a championship with the
Cavs he retired oh wow but he was he was
a Nick and he was I love shum good
Storyteller too yeah he's good on
podcast but I mean like that the amount
of disrespect to say to a guy you had a
good game and the game's not over like
just enjoy that you had this yeah like
he just didn't he was it's I feel like
the world kind of went to [__] when Kobe
died I feel like things were okay before
that you got I think he got something
there it was just that was like January
before Co yes wow I think he got
something there and our buddy Adam Glenn
textt me before it happened cuz he works
for TMZ and he was like Kobe's [__]
dead and I said shut the [__] up no he's
not and he goes I I I know you love
basketball I know you love Kobe and like
I was like [__] damn that day was the
worst that was a sad day and the end of
AR's career
they both died that
day we got to have Ari back on here yeah
I I [__] miss Ari I feel like I get
an occasional like Hoops text from him
but I don't see you cuz I don't work the
stand you see him more than I see he
actually called I haven't seen him in a
minute but he called me and he goes hey
do you have this bit and we ended up
talking for like an hour and a half cuz
he's just he's a fun guy yeah he's a fun
like he's just like a good fit on this
pod too he's just like I just kind of
miss his energy he can roll with
anything and he's doing Adrian IP
paluchi special and with Lou with Lou
and uh he's like she has a bit do you
have this bit and I was like no it's a
little different it's all good and I'm
excited about the special cuz uh I love
her Lou's producing it Lou's pumped
about it and she's got maybe top 10
jokes favorite jokes of mine ever where
she go I probably said it on the Pod
before I think so but say it again here
we one more time Adrian I paluchi shout
out we should definitely have her on at
some point to promote that but yeah uh
my my boyfriend threaten to kill himself
and I was like oh great now I can't kill
myself or people are going to think we
were in love oh wow that's [__]
brilliant that's powerful that's like a
yeah great joke yeah I I I emailed Lou
the other day like at like 2 a.m. cuz I
just been rewatching Louie me too and I
was just like hey man I haven't seen you
around in a while but like just want to
let you know like I'm just happy the
show exists yeah and he wrote me this
like long thoughtful email back and uh
well he took two years off so he's got
some time but he's coming back he uh
that show is like everything I love
about uh like so much like the comedy
Seller New York City Comedy just his
comedy in general uh New York like the
way they portray New York in that city
as like as like a character against him
yes like like the way when there's uh
you know when there's drilling outside
his place and then it's just in his
apartment they just drilling exactly or
you know the the SE the episode where he
uh I mean you should pull this clip
where he's
Louie misses his flight you know what
I'm talking about oh wait is that the
one where he has the vibrator in the bag
and all that no no it's the woman tells
him why he missed his flight it's like
this to me is a road comic this just hit
so [__] hard is it the one where he
sitting next to the fat guy no no he's
talking to a woman at a desk no he's
talking to a woman at a desk hello fresh
is America's number one meal kit they
send pre-portioned ingredients with
delicious recipes straight to your door
it's way cheaper than takeout and you'll
never waste money on excess food with
over 40 recipes and more than 100
seasonal add-on items to choose from
every week you'll keep finding new meals
to love uh yeah this stuff's great uh
they got all kinds of good options and
uh it's good if you want something
quickly uh you know we're all busy and
oh yeah it's good ingredients you you
get it in there hellofresh even has
breakfast you can make in a pinch and
fast 10-minute lunches and since
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day hellofresh is giving all
subscribers free breakfast for life with
every every single hellofresh delivery
hell yeah go to hellofresh.com drunk
free and use code drunk free for free
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box while subscription is active
that's free breakfast forlife at
hellofresh.com drunk free with code
drunk free hellofresh America's number
one meal kit I mean the episode with
Seinfeld is so [__] funny that yeah
Jas there like William Stevenson is in
it you see G all these people like I
watched the rewatch the poker scene with
Hannibal and Norton and Rick Chrome yeah
it's crazy to see all these Comics it
was a different time yeah it's got It's
like it just speaks to me it's just like
a you
know oh yeah that went viral yeah all
right yeah oh you're not going to play
it I'm asking you oh yeah I saw it okay
yeah this was big misgenders you
intentionally while she's while he's
talking you're talking you just
misgender again okay
multiple times got both of you
have wasn't intentional but if you want
to take it personal that's also well she
did do it intentionally twice talking to
you said she and then you said he you're
being condescending and if you want to
continue I have full authority to escort
you out the building right this moment
if you want to play that game with me
okay would you like to continue 3 days
before Christmas I really don't
mind damn that guy is he stayed in the
pocket cuz he you could tell he was
Furious and he could have been like get
the [__] but he just kept it pretty uh
cordial yeah but you could feel the
anger it was like impressive how you
could feel the anger but he still kept
it together for me it was like the
activist was saying this is my power and
I'm going to use it every which way I
can and then he ran up against someone
with a little more power than him and he
was like I'm folding oh interesting
inter like oh you can kick me off the
flight my little my little power [__] is
nothing against what you have which is
TSA saying cuz I want I want to get on
that flight I want to get on flight and
we've been on I've been on both sides of
that we're like I've been the guy who
loses it a little bit because sometimes
they just [__] you I've had them I've
had them shut the door in my face when
they didn't have to do that CU they just
you run into Power hungry people totally
occasionally but I've also seen people
mistreat them and I mean that's one of
my [__] bits in my last special is a
woman's just abusing a TSA woman and
verer and I just start [__] roasting
her ass until Gary threatens to take his
dumb shirt off and he blew it cuz she
called him short he goes you should see
me with my shirt off I'm like dude that
is not good yeah you know we had we
we're good comedians we could have just
killed her here but uh but we had her
but like so it's like when it's
unwarranted but I have seen it where
they are just [__] [__] it's like
dude they do have power over you they
have power over your schedule that can
impact your life like oh yeah that you
don't know what that person's traveling
for exactly exactly I mean Mark just
went on vacation L today I mean
like there's a guy who's reluctant to
take any time off and then he does he's
like I knew I shouldn't have taken time
off I know you're thinking that I was I
was totally but at one time and they
they take it all so seriously these TSA
people and even though they hate their
job it's just a [__] [__] job but
they're like you know I'm I'm like I'm
basically I'm an airport cop I have
power over the airwaves and all this
[__] and I was running to catch a door
and I it was closing and I put my foot
in it and the guy closed the door on my
foot
and he and he goes are you crazy and you
want to be like I get it you're a TSA
guy but he looked at me like I was
[__] oh they say it like you punched
a cop yeah exactly and I'm like Do's not
closed I'm trying to be silly about it
like hey Do's not closed I can get in
there and he goes you're you're a
messing with TSA and this is a federal
offense and I'm like it's a [__] door
at the end of the day I know we got to
pretend it's this airport horeshit but
it's a god it's literally like the floor
is lava and your life We're Not Kids
dude I I yeah I had a thing
that we were the person couldn't get the
door open on the you know for the uh for
the bags when you have to gate check
your bags cuz it's one of those tiny
planes and we all have connect flights
and the person's like I don't know how
to open it and I'm like [__] it and
we're just like all losing it we see
that one guy was like and you're just
like all right you got to chill the [__]
out like this isn't worth I don't give a
[__] if I miss but like uh but then like
I tried to open the door to get help and
he's like what are you doing you could
shut down the whole airport I'm like
well then you're a shitty airport right
right you run into the TSA person
occasionally I I travel with you know
pepper spray sometimes just in my bag
cuz like sometimes you'll see like I
take long walks in some of these
unsavory areas sometimes cuz I'm like
I'm a city person I like to walk and we
stay downtown but you know sometimes you
see like lunatics running at you and I
don't use it ever but it's just like you
have it on you in case in case they have
a weapon or something you're like okay I
can just like handle this but they took
the guy took it he's like you can't
travel with this and I'm like what's
that annoying thing though now where
it's like I can't you can't order it to
New York like it's legal in New York but
you can't order it to New York yeah you
know what I mean oh yeah right there's
one place on 48th Street that sells it
but you can only buy two a year yeah and
they [__] keep track of you is that
right yeah well I hate cuz look I get it
there's rules it's an airport people
lives at stake but you know if I don't
put the tray up and we land we'll be
fine you know or if I don't put my seat
on maybe that's what happened on that
Alaska flight yeah But I do it I play
but sometimes you're like all right so I
I was in first class I was in like 1B I
was in the window on the first row I get
off the plane and I go I left my airpods
on the seat literally sitting right on
the seat so I turn around real quick I'm
like the second guy or third guy off the
plane and I go hey I love my airpods and
the lady goes it's a federal fence to
come back on and I'm like I get it we
got the Spiel but I can just pick them
up and I'll be at them out of your hair
and she's well can you get them like I
don't get what well she's like we have
to wait till everybody deboards that's
the procedure and you're like I get it I
know it but there's a what do you call
that uh something of the law oh you
letter of the law Spirit of the law
Spirit of the law there's a spirit of
the law which is like hey you're not
allowed to speed but if my wife is
pregnant and she's going into labor I'd
like to get to the hospital so I'm going
to speed and they kind of go all right I
go go go so there's that so I'm like
it's right there I'll knock it out I
know you got your rules but this is
different kind of and the pilot heard me
bitching and he goes I got it and he
walks over and he grabs it and hands it
to to me and it was all over so it's
like you could do it but I get this
rules but like come on it's literally
it's literally like teachers's pet
annoying yes where you're like you don't
have to be this way is there homework
are we going to have homework tonight
you know all that [__] I want homework
home yeah you're like dude please oh
yeah I got some [__] I got some I wrote
some stuff down you got bits or peeves I
got a peeve hell yeah I use you ever go
to one of these bathrooms where the
toilet's facing the wrong way the toilet
it's like a single and the toilet facing
the door I'm like oh cool so now if the
Lock's broken some guy's just going to
get a [__] full dose of full frontal
here you know what I mean I'm like I'm
literally facing the door I think that
happened I mean I can't remember if it
was I know okay I went to see Lily
Tomlin once yeah in in Red Bank New
Jersey oh wow and and uh my biological
father's wife is like best friends with
her cuz cuz she was her hairdresser for
years for like all the shows so we're
back we're backstage and I'm peeing and
I'm pretty sure L tman saw my dick oh
wow lesbian yeah didn't it didn't do
anything for her but uh I was kind of
like I was like you got to fix cuz I
think the do the toilet was F it I don't
remember check of the C Bassy theater
maybe I'm wrong on this one but I was in
a toilet recently where that happened
I'm like yeah that's like who the hell
designed that yeah just a dude who he's
like I'm not washing my hands I'm in a
[__] hurry yeah I got to get out
let's be honest that crack in the in the
stall is is enough you can get a look in
there with that that hinge yeah totally
how about the journals that have a
mirror have you seen it seen this I
haven't seen that I don't want to see
myself yeah what that so you could do
your makeup while you're pissing yeah
right well you know it's an all-gender
bathroom but I don't like the mirror in
the the barber shop I I got to look at
my dumb face for half an hour this is an
eternity now where you guys at on on the
phone at the barber
if I get a text sometimes I'll like peek
but just to make sure it's not like
important but yeah I don't I try not to
check same here but I see guys just
fullon like and then I think well that's
rude but then I go well what's the
difference it's not affecting the
haircut yeah it's kind of a bummer cuz I
feel like in every sitcom the guy and
his Barber are like boys and they're
like talking [__] I've never really had
a barber where I'm like [__] uh you
know what do you think about uh Randall
last night you know no it's always like
my friend how you want like uh little
off the sides
okay [__] you don't even speak
English you Russian weirdo I it's also
same I'm always like I never even
remember I don't know how I don't ever
remember they're like what number blade
on the side I'm like I don't [__] I
don't remember either all I know is
round the back you go round I go round
yeah I don't know if I go round or let
me see oh that's round baby I'm round
I'm round and ready to
pound I spin you right round baby right
round yeah but I hate getting haircut
it's the worst yeah I [__] hate it
you know what the thing sometimes I'll
go too short so I look like [__] just so
I don't have to go back for a while it's
just like an annoying thing straight in
the middle of your day I I don't I don't
like it I don't like it either I tried
to run this as a bit but it was too
stupid about how like my wife comes back
she's like I got it washed and then me
and the girls talked about the 90-day
fiance and I got a glow up and all this
and I'm like man I got yelled at by a
Ukrainian guy and I paid out of the ass
and and I got the [__] out of there and
now I hate myself it's such a the man
vers woman haircut is such a different
experience but it depends cuz a lot of
them see you know like you know Korean
ladies or something so so sometimes they
don't have the the the banter always
right right I mean sometimes they do but
sometimes they're just there there's a
language barrier but uh yeah I tried to
do one where I'm like I won't make
reservations at the barber shops so I
always get the shitty Barber yeah the
the guy who's untaken so they're like
well all the allstar Barbers like us are
taken but that guy in the propeller had
in the cor is all yours H stabby get
over here stabby yeah but uh that
doesn't really work either oh I like it
I I try to a thing also about the
difference between men and women like uh
Health well not health care but like
body upkeep like women go to Spas they
get the the Cucumber the mud bath the
deep tissue and guys are like rub and
tug that'll keep me up to date yeah I
get in I get out I get you I get off you
know this lady's doing a fullon health
day and he's like let's make it quick I
I think um I
think we we like women listening to us
complain about this right now we're so
[__] annoyed because of how long a
hair appointment for a woman takes oh
yeah that's true we're literally like 20
minutes in and out and it's annoying and
women are there for like 3 hours 3 hours
and by the way it's like $400 sometimes
or something crazy like that yeah have
you ever seen a woman get the uh the
coloring and they've got the foil out
with the different layers of foil and
there's like 18 pieces of foil and then
the painting of the it's it's a Banana's
job and you're like I am so glad I don't
have to sit through that it looks so
weird so weird do you get [__] HBO
with that thing no I know and then they
come out they look great but in the
process you're like whoa I don't want to
see the sausage being made cuz it is
wild it's like alien like you your
haircuts getting more expensive too they
go way up I don't I don't I never really
got right now my place is expensive just
cuz I just started going to one like
right by me but like they you when I
live on the upper west side they were
[__] I was getting away with like $28
haircuts for like New York that's pretty
damn good oh I remember 14 back in the
day 14 was big and you give him a 20 I
want Blake on this show dude oh he's a
cool guy met him I love Blake he's a
funny guy he's a funny guy and he's
super nice and he's I think still
retired so maybe we maybe not Blake are
you listening dude hit him up there
Peters we we're yeah we're fans yeah I
like Blake he did my show at New York
comedy club and I'll tell you all the
women were Swoon in he's [__] he was
an incredible I mean he had a run where
he was just like embarrassing people he
became the dude that like you wanted to
hurt on the other team cuz he was
throwing down disrespectful dunks and I
kind of love that he might be the last
white he's not white American he's half
is he he's got to be half he looks like
Michelle wolf he's got to be half white
pull up pull it give that him Wikipedia
I think he's a halfy is that a
term I
guess he's gotta be half Irish or
something right yeah g g an Irish name
that Detroit year [__] up his career
he got no respect for because he was
playing hurt and he took him to the
playoffs on like one leg and I think it
just [__] his leg
up there you go cuz he was like still
balling at you he was awesome he did a
roast he was kind of like getting in the
comedy world for a minute he did
Montreal with one year I remember yeah
he just did a thing with like stavi just
talked with him about something really
yeah he he he likes Comics okay great
afro Haitian descent and Gail Griffith
uh Griffin his wife his mother is white
thank
you there you go hey Obama as well half
white I'll take for that hey we get no
love on the white side yeah all right
yeah they always say half black instead
of half white exactly so that was like
remember JL kova yeah he had a great bit
about he's like we got our first black
pres like slow down half black you know
he had a whole thing it was really funny
and he's half black so he's the guy to
do it I sound like Gilbert godfried half
black I got let me try yeah give me a
bit let me try one on you has this been
done I'm worried this has been
done you know as you know a lady I'm
seen has a little Pooch oh yeah and I
take winred uh on walk so you know I'm
picking up the poop and it's those same
doggy bags forever those thin little
bags you pick up the poop you feel
everything and I'm like this is the
worst I feel everything and then I [__]
in a condom and I'm like I feel nothing
I like it I like it and you can [__]
the ass this poop it really you feel the
poop with your dick well it's still uh
it really depends on what you're doing
right right also well they're both warm
yeah that's true the [__] is warm so is
the vagina it's a good point you want to
wear the glove to to you know it's gross
it's poo and you want to wear the condom
yeah so you don't get the bad part the
the pregnant or the infected so yeah
yeah you're trying not to get something
bad yeah I see both there something here
though yeah definitely I like it you see
both on the ground in New York I see
bags of [__] and condoms I guess it
depends on the [__] right
oh I don't want to use [__] of the
punch though damn but you know I think
it's like uh you know
who is a rust manev you of a joke like
you see a condom on the street and
you're like who is this mixed up mystery
man he's like he's wless enough to have
sex in the street yet responsible enough
to put a condom on oh yeah oh maybe the
angle is your girlfriend gets mad if you
don't have both ready you know maybe
she's like you know hey you got to take
Winnie out and ready bring ready bring a
bag and then you're like Hey we're going
upstairs you better bring a bag you know
and and you're like you better a condom
[__] what really still yeah I guess it's
like funny it's like yeah well the
problem is one you want to feel yeah
true I've never been like man I want a I
want a raw dog pick up this poop yeah
maybe that's the angle whoever's making
the dog ra dog oh that's good well maybe
whoever's making the bag should make
condoms those two should come together
the the condom guy should make the [__]
pick up yeah you know you you'll never
see extra thin doggy bags
yeah you need a magnum doggy doggy style
also by the way true there's a lot here
I think oh Winnie [__] we got we'll
have Winnie back next week it sucks when
she's not here I know the comments just
a good energy they love Winnie in the
comments everyone no who could see that
dog if you see that little Pooch and you
and you're angry you got to look within
yeah that's true that dog's a mirror
yeah I like that oh that's big I like I
think you got something with the bag
there Trojan should make make dog bag
dog [__] bags yeah yeah four your
pleasure means you feel nothing right
right yeah that's
good then you're like oh I got a little
there was a hole in
it I broke
it what do you got remember Taran
condoms those are the those were wild
nights yeah I remember we were riffing a
bit about uh I think you used me in one
of your old old bits where I was like I
you were like my friend he's an he's
like you should uh you should put water
in the cond to make sure the girl didn't
poke a hole in them yeah oh yeah how'
that go was like yeah that turns on
women suspicion and paranoia oh yeah
sound like an old Norman bit I'm in the
sink like hold on honey let me just
check this although Drake did that [__]
that's true that's true oh he put hot
sauce in it right yeah which for some
reason women got mad at him he's like
hey I'm just you know I'm trying to kill
this Kidz one of the things you get mad
at but what you're doing is pretty
[__] ex
exactly uh
uh uh okay is this anything so uh you
know I'm getting older and I discovered
I have a gluten intolerance I still eat
it but you know it it [__] me up but
it's hard cuz my mom is like a chef big
Italian foodie lady so she's making
pasta pizza she bakes her own bread so I
go back home and she's like I baked a
giant loaf of whatever and I almost have
to come out to my foodie Mom that I'm
gluten-free and it's uh it's almost like
she's trying to set me up with a woman
and I'm like I can't have the yeast or
or something something there where I'm
it's almost like coming out that's what
I'm saying gay guy yeah you're like
almost like
uh I'm coming out of the closet I can't
have gluten I'm coming out of the pantry
it's funny for like the South it's like
it could be funny if the angle was like
your family's like liberal so this is
like your version of having to be like
I'm gay yeah yeah yeah saying you won't
eat bread and she's like oh my God I
never saw this
coming yeah [__] yeah she's like
uh I tried the yeast line and that that
did pretty well but that feels like
there's more there yeah you so she's
making pizza pasta and you're like I
can't eat any of this [__] yeah and I'll
eat it but I'll puke yeah like it
disgusts me like a
vagina yeah I'll eat it but I'll I'll
feel I'll feel like I'll I'll feel like
[__] afterwards yeah yeah I'll regret it
I'll feel bad I'll be like oh I'm only
doing it for you yeah it's not permanent
maybe yeah there's maybe something about
like uh make maybe it's like a
conversation you're having with a gay
friend oh yeah he like oh I had to
[__] pretend to oh that's good be
straight for my family and you're like
tell me about it I have to I can't eat
any of my mom's uh bread yeah you know
like uh and then we can compare like I
know women make me sick I'm like bread
makes me sick huh
or maybe he did come out maybe he was
like I told him I
was oh maybe he shows up with his
boyfriend and I have to show up with
gluten-free flour and they're both like
oh this is horrible I'll play with it
you never told me this yeah maybe it
could be maybe more subtle you never
told me this was this was something you
liked right they'll just do all the the
things people say to a gay guy yeah what
else would they say also there gay bars
and I have to go to these I have to go
to certain restaurants how long have you
known
oh that's good we're like uh I was born
this
way I just yeah you know I used to eat I
used to eat regular bread but I
knew that's something like I used
to yeah and I'll still shovel it down
because you know I can go both ways but
I prefer the no bread so yeah I could
tell when I was doing it on stage it was
they were like uh uh and then it isn't
that the worst yeah so I think L like
it's literally like you're like [__]
someone good new dick just stops working
yes yes they're like oh here it comes
baby and then nothing like sorry yeah
all right you got others I got I got I
got yeah I got others hit me with
another one all right let me try one um
see what we
got let me see
um we got Liz sending me pictures of her
pug oh that could have gone that could
that that could have been real dirty oh
uh I someone a woman I know sent me a
picture of her uh
breastfeeding and uh and she wrote sorry
if that's the female equivalent of a
dickpic and I was like if I send you one
of my penis and a baby sucking that's
worse is that something that's funny
that's funny yeah well she didn't write
back
haha oh well well it's funny because I
used to have a joke about how like
breasts are private parts but if you're
breastfeeding it's it's okay it's okay
but it doesn't work with
a a shirtless man like a shirtless man
is okay but if I breastfeed I go to jail
or something like that like my kids look
at my nipple I went I went way dirtier
and darker yeah baby sucking me off
that's true that is
dark well I'm saying I wouldn't do it
right why don't you could do something
madebe with a dog like something you
hear that Aaron Rogers I wouldn't do it
don't be talking no [__] yeah
fouchy yeah yeah that's a tough one
breastfeeding well it's tough cuz oh
maybe there's something like we like
tits but when you put a baby on now it's
like nurturing and serious it's weird no
one's like woo baby you know like tits
are fun until you put a baby on it now
it's real yeah tits are
uh yeah baby really uh a baby shows up
and tits become like a job yes yes it's
almost like it's almost like lunge break
lunch break then a baby shows up back to
work right but like it's uh
yeah baby runes yeah like it's not hot
when you're using something as its
function yes that's
interesting right trying to think of you
know it's like uh Hey Oh no that's no
good
um you know if you're like you you you
use an
apple you're like hey I like an apple
but then some guy's like I'm going to
make a bong with it or something yeah
something well that that bong is
actually better than an apple yeah all
right hold on but there's a Perfect
Analogy here an actual function like
something like uh oh maybe you got a A
Beer funnel and someone's like hey we
got to fix this pipe we need that funnel
or something some where you use it for
the actual real
thing takes the fun out of itose using
it for the real thing or like uh anal
sex anal sex what do you mean anal sex
is fun but oh I see oh that's
interesting I'm not a big anal SE gu
we've been through this I'm not
either um
yeah the function but it's weird because
dicks are scary either way that's
interesting like if I show you my dick
in a photo it's like whoa you do there's
no
kid involved that was the joke I was
making though yeah that's true but the
sucking is where it gets scary to too
offensive you think uh well pull off
I'll throw it up at the cell tonight
we'll see what it hits even if there a
maybe you could be like look even if
there a kid in the photo with me don't
have to be sucking yeah it's a
clientless joke in there the function
thing is interesting to me yeah use it
for its
function god there's things out there
that we're not thinking of all right
hold on all right we're getting we're
getting uh we're getting weary here yeah
what do you got um is this
anything uh a this is stupid did I do
the Yelp joke on you I think I did I
don't know where I I I love Yelp because
it's not helpful at all it's just like a
it's it's like a therapy session
disguise is a restaurant review you know
you read the comments like how's this
Thai restaurant and some lady's like I
went to the restaurant the waiter looked
like my ex-husband who died 1989 of
leukemia I cried at the table the
napkins were soft four stars and you're
like I don't know anything about the
food but I know you're bipolar or
whatever and then I'm like this is not
helpful at all and my friend goes that's
why you can't Yelp sucks now cuz people
are entitled they complain people didn't
act like that in the 50s and I go well
you can't have Yelp in the 50s it would
just be a bunch of black people like we
didn't get in and that kills and I'm
like uh I do a whole act out where I'm
like it look good through the window
though maybe we'll go back in 14 years
and then I do a whole thing about how
the internet if the internet was around
back then it would be super dark you
know like a Native American guy like
[__] Cheesecake Factory they built it on
my TP and they don't take pelts or
something like that but I don't know
where to go with it well that's a that's
a whole another big premise the first
part seems done but the second part is
like how dark the internet would have
been right right that might be too big I
we already have footage of
JFK think about how graphic that [__]
would be yeah and I almost don't want to
open that can of worms of a bit cuz it
that could be a huge it's huge well it's
huge it's just you have to that's the
problem is you're casting such a wide
net like you got to find what it is MHM
um I thought about like fire hose
spraying black Bui and they're like you
know I barely got a sip one star oh
Pepsi Pepsi oh no like like a Smart
Water
ad yeah yeah Smart
Water yeah yeah I got a lot of like bits
that are like the beginning works then
it falls off a cliff too I [__] stink
yeah comedy's hard comedy's [__] hard
bro like you have an hour cooking you're
going to do a
special at one point those jokes were
not working like some will work out of
the gate if you're lucky but most of
them you had to work at and you had to
Tinker with you're going to have to edit
some of this stuff
quiet time here yeah you can edit this
right this is like a very broad idea but
something I thought of is like I read
that a study that five alcoholic drinks
per week could shorten your life but I
think the problem is for most people
without alcohol life is too long oh you
know what I mean like alcohol is like
editing like you you're talking to
someone bored alcohol is like a director
it's like a it's like an editor it's
making key edits yeah true like someone
keeps talking you're like oh my God cut
here we'll cut here and I'm back you
know like I don't know how to say this
interesting it's like an observation
it's not it's [__] tr I stink no I
mean it's I do that with the family you
know your family function you go to
Thanksgiving and you're like 10 minutes
in you're like I need a drink I'm
talking to Nana I'm talking to Aunt
Susie I'm talking to [__] Uncle Bob
and I'm I'm Uncle Bob's telling about
work and Susie telling me about her cat
I'm dying here I need a drink yeah it's
nothing what else you got drinking's
like an
editor um also it's who's got the time
travel bit you know you ever like
driving somewhere you start drinking
you're like that's a TA that's a ta so
true so that's yeah maybe that's too
close anyway so [__] that bit uh
right oh oh I had something I lost it
hold on I'll find it [__] God damn it
where did it go oh this is stupid just
oh my [__] sucks punch me right in the
balls here um I'll try just tell me no
and then I got another one my doctor
goes uh I went did a check up and he
goes how you sleeping I go I'm sleeping
horribly and he goes well look it's your
chart says you're drinking a lot you're
probably not sleeping cuz you're
drinking I'm like well I don't think
that's true because every time I sleep I
drink I pass out you know and like no
one goes to a bar sees a guy passed out
and goes that guy's
sober only problem is it's like you know
you you fall asleep but it's just bad
sleep I know it's it's one of those like
the logic is bad in the joke maybe
that's part of it though maybe you say
like isn't it weird though cuz alcohol
helps me fall asleep it's just it keeps
waking you up yeah I guess so it's
almost like
uh but you you're like you're pass it's
like you fall asleep the way a guy like
knocks you
out oh yeah it's not like it's not like
you fell asleep in a healthy way that's
true but on paper you are sleeping
you're sleeping you know so it it is a
gray area but yeah I sleep like [__]
when I'm drunk same all right yeah let
me try a real one a real one all right
my friend we were me and our friend a
black guy and we were I was like man my
comments look how mean these comments
are just on YouTube and everything and
he was like oh your comments are mean he
showed me it's just like all nword N
word N word and I was like all right
well you got me there yeah and you got
to stop posting that's what I said
that's part of the joke sorry I wrote
that that hits but then I go uh I go it
sucks about the nword thing because you
just get called that if you could find a
way to do an only fans for racist wow
that's funny so if you could get their
money like yeah just call me anything
and you could pay me it's like only fans
like I'll show you my tit I'm not going
to show you my tits at work but if you
pay me I'll show you send it all to
Howard
University yeah and then eventually you
can make so much money you can like give
it back to the community and how'd you
build the rec center oh Kanye got on the
rac's only fans so you know it lit up or
you could do it with Palestine and Jews
you could do it everything and now
you're making money off the hate yeah
but I it's it's one of those jokes where
people are like Whoa man what are you
talking about are you try to promote I
think there's something there I think
that's there too like when I say racist
only fans they're like what you you want
to be racist like no they should make
only fans for racist and I like that way
you can just you know they're they're
going to want to I guess the only
problem is why would they pay to because
they can do it for free that's the hard
part I can't crack it's literally Free
Speech yeah hate speech but it's free
speech that's true that's true that's I
guess that's the flaw with the bit
because it's a it's clever but if they
could say it to you like you're just
standing there and they go all right say
it and you goty you get a guy going all
right he says on FaceTime or Zoom
something like that Twitter should
should penalize you should have to pay
for Twitter and they penalize your
account if you if you if you call
someone a slur right right that would
never happen no but if you go to this I
don't want to pay for Twitter so it's a
terrible idea I know I know it's tough
It's it's if I could find a way around
that part where they sa it for free
already yeah because if you're G if
they're going to say you might as well
get paid for it yeah absolutely yeah pay
wall plus if you put anything behind a
pay wall it slows down so if you got
racism behind a pay wall it would cut it
down like 70% maybe that's the angle
more like man it's like we got to we got
to start we got to get racism behind a
pay wall CU then they're going to be
like man we're wasting money yeah yeah
it's like I have a podcast I used to
love they went behind a pay wall I don't
even listen anymore yeah it's the same
with the nword you know like you're
you're in a car you're in a car accident
with an Asian guy you're like man if I
could afford it I would really oh I got
to sign up [__] it you know yeah it's
just it's all clever it's just not
practical mhm you got to find a way to
make it actually work yeah the logic
isn't all
there it's hey man this is what bits
this what look our bad and average is
not horrible it's just what about this
yeah hit me okay I might have cracked it
you black people should copyright the
n-word copyright it now every time they
say it you get royalties [__] uh what's
that word reparations get royalties
because if they copyright like Trump
copyrighted uh your fired didn't
he I think he did or he tried to so now
when you say you got to pay him black
people should copyright the nword so if
you say the nword then the guy says
You're Fired both of them have to pay
up yeah yeah I don't know but like you
know we play music on here and they're
like whoa whoa don't play music you got
to pay the royalties what if that was
like that with the
nword I know it's it's a it's
there's something here though I I hear
you it's just it's [__] hard this we
look we're showing the ugliness of this
process that's kind of cool yeah I guess
so let me run one on yeah please so I I
was remembering like I used to be a kid
this is how I'm trying to do this bit I
used to be like same here I used to be a
kid we all did and uh when I was like
seventh grade I was lactose intolerant
and really yeah and but you know when
you're told that you're like [__] that
[__] I I'll Rebel so I just eat pizza
like every meal and uh you know Big Mac
stuff like that and you're like uh oh
you just you're just like [__] it I'm
gonna I'm gonna fight back and then I
remember one day you know we'd go see
movies in Times Square we'd like double
up we get one ticket you just see movies
all day and I was in a Time Square
bathroom just like [__] my brains
out just like horrible and uh like
liquid out of me and through the crack I
hear a black boy black uh boy and his
father go uh the dad goes that boy has
got the shits and they started laughing
and they like high fived I was like it's
so weird that like a low point in your
life is like a bonding moment for
another person's I think that's where
like the angle is maybe sure where
you're like that's probably like you
know like for me I was like man I got to
like I got to like turn my life around
but for them they were like that was the
closest I ever felt to my father you
know what I mean I don't know what it's
like a funny observation that is funny
but it's so true like Charlie Sheen that
whole thing where he was melting down
the whole country was like whoa this is
amazing yeah yeah it brings people
together ironically when someone else is
other people misery brings you together
we watch intervention as a family you
know like this is the saddest point in
this guy's life isn't that weird yeah a
guy gets you know like a football thrown
is nuts you send it to your friend on
Instagram like dude look at this yeah
you're bonding maybe the angle could be
CU that's good maybe the angle could be
like that's what people should do to
bring other people together forget like
make a wish and all this I've got to you
got to [__] your life up just to help
other people like [__] Superman I get
the shits I'm bringing people together I
don't know somehow you can manufacture
horrible things just to help someone
else I don't
know yeah for like uh it's like City
Harvest or something like for a benefit
yeah like come see thisy I feel like uh
yeah some see some see this guy
uh yeah I feel like I know [__] up not
though that's what the internet's become
that's the problem it's like the
internet has become like watch me eat
this [__] um I you get a free burrito
if you can eat this eight pound burrito
in in 10 minutes you just watch a guy do
horrible [__] to his body and you're
like that's like entertainment now yeah
and you kind of love the guy for some
reason you're like look at this guy
because then he's putting himself
through misery for our entertainment
well I think that's why America's
Funniest Home Videos was a hit cuz
people were like sure I got kicked in
the nuts by a Shetland pony but I made
10 grand and now I'm famous did they get
10 grand for a video if you won well if
you won the the number one prize man it
sucks to not win I know but you were on
TV I guess that was something back in
the '90s you go home you go to school
you're like I was on America funny I
kicked my dad the
balls I don't know man but at least it
was a win stink I got nothing new I feel
like my new [__] is like either hitting
or it's just garbage like this right
yeah same we'll figure it out we'll
figure it out and I've been getting some
nice messages like hey have you thought
about this angle have you tried that and
some people are really uh on it I got a
wreck please the book it's short book
the friends of Eddie Coy it's supposed
to be a great movie too I want to yeah
Robert mitcham's in the movie oh wow I
haven't seen it I'm going to watch it
it's [__] awesome it's like 200 Pages
it's like easy read it's like a cool ass
old school like Boston Noir oh really
yeah it's really cool okay um good
writing um boy you do a lot of reading I
was in a bookstore in Springfield
Missouri and they just like I pulled
over the back and Ross McDonald was one
of the quotes being like this is an
awesome book and I was like all right I
like his [__] so I was like I'll check
it out I like noirs I just like the
language and stuff and I like like
seeing plots unfold yeah I like that too
but you know what I don't like about
books is I don't like people seeing what
I'm reading like are you on the train
with that thing then you get some guy
going hey Eddie Cole read that last year
I used to read A Confederacy of Dunes on
the train yeah and I got a million
people like oh great book and I was like
let me read the [__] thing it's nice
but it was like interrupting me I was on
the flight so I don't care I just I kind
of like the feel of a book more than a
Kindle I stopped using a Kindle I I
Kindles are awesome but I I just I I
hate having another thing to
charge yeah between the phone and the
computer and I actually like I have one
of those this is so stupid I said I hate
having other things to charge but I use
regular books and I I have one of those
neck light things for bed cuz I cuz
sometimes flights get dark too but uh
neckl wow nerd alert they're like 20
bucks are great really yeah they're
[__] awesome that's a wreck get get a
next to cuz you sleep next to someone
they might be sleeping and that way you
can still read I'm going to get one of
those when I eat my yeah that's one I
have they're like 20 bucks they're great
oh wow that one looks a little too cheap
look at that okay yeah the Kindle it's
like a sex robot you want the real thing
you want the book you know that's good
and then you're like I don't want
another thing to
charge that's funny you should you
should try there's something there take
it that's you I don't use a Kindle so
that's you
um any Rex uh let's see I saw a movie oh
anatomy of a fall yeah I love that very
good that was killer I watched it very
good heavy duty good dialogue too great
dialogue did we talk about this already
mat you might have brought it up and
then I watched it I got on fight with
Ron on cuz I thought the uh the snow
movie with the uh the rugby team that
that lands in the snow on Netflix it's
like I think it's Argentinian or
something something yeah you liked it I
didn't like it that much oh and he did
and he was like and he's a [__] tanon
hates everything he was like I thought
it was great I was like really I thought
the dialog was weak I did watch it
dubbed so that might have been my
problem Oh but yeah he's uh he's a hater
oh yeah I feel like he only really likes
movies for the most part if it's like
just misery yes if it's just like
painful and like brutal than he likes it
totally look at that [__] killer
score yeah oh man it was a it was a good
script I thought I like the uh anatomy
of a fall yeah totally wreck that one
that was cool yeah de kid it has a lot
of great twists and turns and it's
really well dog is beautiful yes what a
cool look I was like man everyone's a
good actor even that [__] dog Snoop
that was an awesome uh yeah and the main
woman was so man it's kind of like I
guess a loaded year for best actors and
stuff because I saw she was nominated I
was like oh she's going against all
these other good actors too but hey M I
feel like movies and [__] is picking up
like they're they're really we had to
score sey Michael did you watch Ferrari
no I got to see it I got to see it too
you know it's a Michael man with the
Adam Driver and the story is incredible
so but I haven't heard anyone talking
about it I think it's out it's out yeah
mention I mean Michael man is just such
a [__] beast I just love Michael I
mean I'm wearing a [__] Michael man
shirt right now dude oh I didn't even
put Thief look at that James Khan all
right yeah no one has brought this up so
I can't imagine it what's the the rotten
T I feel like it's got to be good though
it's it's Michael man I'm going to watch
it all right all right 72 I'll take a 72
74 all right yeah it's worth seeing
that's a C+ I bet it's cool though the
story is really good just the real story
I don't know anything about it oh cool
cool this guy uh it was Lamborghini and
Ferrari they hated each other and they
one was a tractor company and then they
were like I bet I could make a better
car and he was like [__] you so he made
a car and then they would race him it's
it's fun damn Italian
can't go wrong with Italians is he is
this the second time he's played an
Italian in a row didn't he just do he
did House of Gucci he did do House of
Gucci but I heard I heard that was good
house a Gucci I heard it was good really
yeah look at that that's pretty good not
bad I mean I mean he definitely he
definitely looks better as Adam Driver
not ugly enough yeah he looks like tlda
Swinton on the left
but there you go yeah those with the hey
Patrick demp he's an actual race car
driver in real life really yeah yeah
that's pretty cool Corolla a couple
other guys actually Cora is like he's
such a manly dude he always talks about
that [__] but I know race cars I asked
him why he does it he goes you know why
cuz when you're on that track you can't
think of anything else I was like all
right I can get that with
booze yeah try drinking yourself stupid
yeah that works that'll work but no I
get it the rush I mean I understand like
there's something it's hard in this day
and age to like actually be present so I
I do get that true true pres and you
heard it from me a guy who can't drive a
regular car you ever see Rush what's
that that's a Ron Howard movie about
rorth yes yeah I saw that it looked good
I didn't it's good it's true story as
well Nikki laa Burns himself up in a car
I don't want to give it away but it's
really good oh you know what's a good
one do you ever see the documentary
Senna on yes great movie that was really
cool great doc yeah that was awesome
that guy was a hunk too I don't [__]
about Formula 1 but that is like the
rage now
man crazy I feel dumb for not cuz people
love it I tried I really tried to watch
it I was kind of bored I'm bored it's I
think you got to get into like the I
think any sport is like you can get into
once you like learn it and know the
rivalries and the personalities and the
politics and all that stuff but uh I'm
just so into the basics I'm I'm just so
into into basketball I like football I
like I like
baseball I like hockey I'm kind of good
I I don't need to keep I mean I need to
do other [__] well the problem with this
is It's So subtle which sounds weird cuz
they [__] crash and go a million
miles an hour but it's just like so not
enough it's basketball there's so much
technique and fundamentals and all these
things happening this is just like well
there's technique in this too but it's
just not as exciting to The Spectator
cuz to them I mean like the angles that
they have to keep hitting but like I'm
watching hoops and there's like it's
more variety like like you're seeing
like an alley you're seen a
three-pointer you're seen a you know an
incredible defensive play it's broken up
more as opposed to the way this is to me
but like I also have talked to people
who love this whose opinions I do trust
so yeah you know it's a little reality
TV for me that that that Formula 1 show
it's like bunch of hot guys
competing it feels like Euro cuz I love
tennis but it does have that tennis Vibe
where they're all wearing like a sick
watch and they're all [__] like sck
hair kind of too hot right right exactly
and they're cocky as [__] and it's cool
and then they [__] crash like that
which is crazy that is the crazy I mean
that makes it extra tragic you're like
his [__]
hair no more I know I mean you get why
women like these guys cuz they're
they're real Daredevils exactly
Daredevil they're hot and they're kind
of Reckless and if they're like dry or
something in the interview that's just
like an added bonus totally totally this
guy who wins them all what's his name
the guy who wins every [__] race for
uh is it Red Bull he wins every race you
know what I'm talking about the left's
pretty hot what's his name he's like a
robot oh really what's his name he's the
best for he's just the number one guy
number one formula one I mean it's
killing me that I can't remember his
[__] name Daniel no not he's supposed
to be cool though he's like the funny
one of the funny ones I think but wait
what's the number one
guy are just searching best formula one
people are calling us stupid in the com
they're yelling at the screen cuz I know
it was like Louis Hamilton for ever but
now it's another guy Hamilton shoeer no
who is it uh it says Hamilton's number
one who is yeah but that's probably old
oh okay shoeer no ven the guy he's he's
like the stud okay he's like he wins so
much that it's like boring it's almost
like everyone's like what what's I guess
we're competing for second place but
these guys all live for stopping for
stopping where do they live Switzerland
or something where's like the Hub
I got we should stop talking about this
we're [__] because we're [__] idiots
but like I look I would love to learn
more about it yeah sure sure why not
it's just a new thing I also think this
is going to sound [__] but I think when
there's a machine involved as a in a
sport it's less cool like I like
fighting or boxing it's just like Bare
Bones B basketball it's like ball and
hoop it's very simple this has a [__]
car in it and exactly and some of the
companies are better yes like so like
like Red Bull and Mercedes make you a
better car so it's like a disadvantage
if you don't get one of the good
companies that takes away from the sport
a lot for sure so yeah I I agree with
that yeah you want the basics like track
yeah tennis is a racket and a ball in a
net that's it tennis I I dig tennis I
love like I've never been to one we
should go to one some I would love to go
to the open list goes every year he I
know maybe we'll go with him yeah sure
the [__] agents will hook us up with
some yeah yeah tennis is awesome I watch
that on the plane a lot because it's
that little screen and I can see it all
yeah hockey I can't watch on is pretty
[__] great Live's great but on screen
I went with little Gary recently we had
a ball and he played hockey and he's
pretty good yeah he's a little ball of
energy that kid he's a little hockey
puck should we wrap this uh bad boy up I
guess so yeah and plus though the ladies
aren't uh aren't hard on the eyes I'm
hard on I'm going to be hard
on all right where are we going to be
here
w a lot of editing on Beacon baby Mark
Norman at the Beacon yeah it's coming up
whenever this comes out it'll be uh soon
uh Beacon New York City hopefully it's
sold out by now Lexington Charlotte San
Antonio Houston Boise Salt Lake Atlanta
Raleigh I'm doing Charleston Austin
Tucson Phoenix Charlottesville El Paso
Albuquerque Memphis Little Rock
Knoxville Chattanooga Syracuse Buffalo
Minneapolis Madison Evansville and la
for the Netflix Fest
what do you got fatty I got Dan Beach uh
I got uh Omaha I got uh [__] OKC is that
next yes Irvine we got Dallas before
that as well love it OKC Irvine Salt
Lake City then the special at the Wilbur
sam.com shows I think it's I think it's
you know uh look at OKC and stuff like
that cuz the others are looking are
looking all right but uh is it's amazing
that like I just talked to Godfrey and
he's like oh was just just in daa beach
and you're like it's amazing there's
enough people in daa beach that are like
we'll go to Godfrey we'll go to you
waterdale yeah I guess
millions billions millions of people I
mean oh
uh yeah there there's people there okay
I just worry I'm like Florida's got
cities that's true oh well that's not a
lot of people not a lot of people but I
guess you get people from all over yeah
it's a big Club too at 375 I know I know
it's a big room hopefully hopefully sell
some CH decent food there too yeah the
club is great great Club one of the top
Florida clubs I'd say yeah all right
folks get some Bodega cat it's on the uh
the interwebs buy a bottle make a paper
plane make a sidec car make a Boulevard
EA and follow Bodega cat Whiskey on IG
let's get those numbers up cuz Mark and
I are trying to get uh some distribution
and we're working very hard on this not
not like that hard but we're trying here
here you got that right yeah we're
pushing I'm I'm connecting with people
then it falls through and then I connect
with guy and that falls through and it's
it's a tough tough sleding yeah so we'll
see you guys thanks for listening tell a
friend queef it up thanks
[Music]
guys I've had a little
too and Norman's talking [__] about the
[__]